Benji Jones: In the summer of 2019,
a bull was found dead on
a farm in North Carolina.
Dead by exsanguination.
Which means it was drained of blood.
The culprit wasn't real-life vampires,
but something just as frightening:
an army of more than 1,000
Asian longhorned ticks.
But here's the thing.
As scary as that sounds,
Asian longhorns are just one
of about 90 tick species found in the US.
All of them suck blood, all
of them can carry disease,
and all of them are
incredibly difficult to kill.
The Asian longhorned tick
is truly a villainous pest.
Not only is it an invasive species,
but it can also clone
itself over and over again.
Since it was first reported in 2017,
it's crawled its way to
at least 12 other states.
Including where we are here, New York.
Danielle Tufts: OK, so this is an adult.
This looks like the Asian
longhorned tick to me.
Jones: So this the infamous
Asian longhorn tick?
Tufts: Yep.
Jones: That's Danielle Tufts,
a disease ecologist at
Columbia University.
She's studying ticks in Staten Island
to figure out what diseases they carry.
But first, she has to collect them.
Tufts: So, this is what
we call a drag cloth,
and it's a meter by
meter, so a meter squared.
And basically what we would do
is we just walk at a nice, even, slow pace
and drag this right behind us.
And we'll stop every
about 20 meters or so,
and we'll flip the cloth over,
and we'll look for whatever
ticks are on the backside.
Jones: Contrary to what
many people believe,
ticks don't actively seek you out.
Tufts: Ah, so here's a tick right here.
Jones: Tick spotted!
So many ticks in this forest.
Tufts: Oh, yeah.
This is a very ticky forest.
Jones: And they're definitely
not jumping on you from trees.
In fact, ticks can't even jump.
They're actually more like opportunists
who take what they can get.
Tufts: Ticks are what we
call sit-and-wait predators,
where they climb up to the
top of the blades of grass
and they put their arms out.
And at the top of their arms
they have little sticky pads.
And those pads will get attracted to this.
And this is how they
get stuck on your pants
or on other animals in the wild as well.
Jones: And what do you call the, like,
when they stick their hands up like this?
Tufts: We call that
questing or host-seeking.
Jones: Yeah, ticks are
literally on a quest for blood!
And they've mastered the
art of extracting it,
all without getting caught.
After a tick crawls onto you,
it sneaks into a concealed
crevice, like your armpit.
And after that, it uses two
horrifying hooklike structures
to tear into your flesh
and keep from falling off.
Then, they insert what
is basically a straw
covered in spikes, like
a piece of barbed wire,
which makes them even harder to remove.
And this sounds like it would hurt, a lot.
But ticks have another
trick up their sleeve,
or rather their mouth.
Saliva.
It's a tick's ultimate
weapon to avoid detection.
It contains pain-numbing properties,
so you don't notice them
even as they stab and rip your flesh.
Plus, it suppresses your immune system,
so the wound is less
likely to get red or itchy.
That's why ticks can stay
in you undetected for days,
even as they grow to several
times their normal size.
And if you do find a tick
in time to get it off,
it won't die easily.
Tufts says that ticks can survive
for as long as two years
without a blood meal.
And they're also masters of the elements.
They can tolerate long periods of drought,
and some species can survive underwater
for two to three days.
So, yeah, flushing them
down the toilet or sink
likely won't kill them.
Tufts: If you put them
in the sink, sometimes
they'll crawl back out of the sink.
Jones: Now, all of this
wouldn't be such a big problem
if it weren't for the diseases they carry.
In the US alone,
they transmit at least
16 diseases to humans.
That's more than any other
insect, including mosquitoes.
Lyme disease alone, for example,
infects an estimated
300,000 Americans each year.
And it's only getting worse.
In 2004, there were about 23,000
cases of tick-borne disease
reported to the CDC.
But by 2017,
that number had almost
tripled to nearly 60,000.
But what isn't clear is why.
Why ticks and the diseases
they carry are spreading.
Though Tufts and other scientists say
that climate change is
at least partly to blame.
Tufts: We've been having
pretty mild winters,
which can promote survival,
overwintering survival of
hosts and of the vectors,
which also will lead to new expansion.
Jones: Whatever the reason,
there are tons of ticks.
Pretty much everywhere.
So, the next time you go for a hike,
keep these tips in mind.
Stay on the trails, where ticks
are less likely to hang out.
Wear bug spray; preferably
something with DEET.
Tuck your pants into your socks,
so nothing can crawl onto your legs.
Wear light clothes, so
anything that does get on you
is easy to spot.
And, of course, always do a tick check
once you're out of the woods.
All right, so we're gonna do a tick check,
which you recommend doing
after you get out of the woods.
Tufts: Absolutely.
Jones: So, crevices...
Tufts: What you want to
look for is on your pants.
I wear rubber boots, so that
they don't crawl up there.
But, like, for here, my pants,
any of these little crevices
along here, I would look for.
Jones: I mean, I feel like those
little guys are definitely,
like, the larvae form are
definitely on me, right?
Somewhere.
Tufts: Maybe, maybe not.
And then you want to check
up around your belt region.
Jones: This is, like, not safe for work.
Tufts: It's also good when
you are hiking with a friend
to check each other.
So, for instance, I would check your back.
Jones: I feel like we're like
chimpanzees or something.
Tufts: Yeah, grooming behavior.
So, you want to check
all along the sleeves,
on anywhere on the back.
Jones: So really, like,
on top of clothing?
Like, you don't need to, like, strip down?
Tufts: No, no, you can strip
down later in the shower.
Jones: Great.